yeah so
as someone who doesn't know much about
chris chan as a whole topic so like what
are some of the most notable things
they've done
or that we can mention i i could say
that i've like garnered them such a
notoriety online i mean at this point is
there anything that they haven't
mentioned
like i don't like like because for me
i'm just like okay so you you talk about
chris christian being like one of the
most documented people probably in
history at this point and just seeing
the first part of your documentary i'm
just like yeah i can see that you know
like i i don't think someone has had
such intimate detail be
leaked or put out into a public space
before but like what are some of them
how did they gain notoriety in the first
place that's what i'm so curious about
um all started in 2007 when uh when
photos of chris were posted on 4chan i
think and then maybe somethingawful.com
yeah i remember that forum website yeah
so um people people connected the dots
and
and uh showed up the pictures as this is
the person who created the sonichu
comics right and look at him it's kind
of like um like a freak gawking right
right which is uh something awful they
usually just like post anything that was
awful quote unquote what they thought
they were just marking yeah yeah and
that was the thing yeah so that's how
that started and chris noticed this and
started making videos
addressing rumors and correcting the
record
yeah right i believe one of the most
worrying things and is where you could
definitely tell this was going to take a
turn for the worst in the documentary
that you made um is that at some point
chris has this brilliant idea uh of just
releasing
everything yeah just right just
handwriting uh an absurd amount of
personal information probably penis
length included at some point in there
you know so yeah like the way that she
fights back is to basically dox herself
yeah which is a really strange strategy
yes
um yeah this was in response to the
encyclopedia dramatica page which was
made about chris chandler at that time
yeah and um apparently according to
chris um they were fed up because they
got a lot of details wrong so i wanted
to correct that and add context to
to to the information which just sounds
like a disaster basically adding a
footnote yeah that's all the information
you see like a fire and you're just like
let's just pour oil on this
that's just
no that's not how you butterfly here let
me help you
jesus yeah and and part
he he called this
task um information overloads
i love that i love that chris kept
calling it that it's like i don't think
that's how it works on the internet
maybe in person
that i would be like wait what
which i imagine he was kind of like um
thinking that the encyclopedia dramatic
page would be like uh
a malfunctioning robot if you if you
feel too much information is it's gonna
explode yeah right you thought you
thought that maybe it's like feeding a
logic bomb to like an ai or something
right yeah so yeah it's like a plot to
like a movie or something and uh
encyclopedia dramatica again is another
drama website right
just uh
encyclopedia of people who uh have done
well drama things and it's literally
just documented there's a lot of yeah
there's numerous websites that are
horrible like that oh yeah i you know uh
it's uh unfortunate that uh some people
go on there and then correct the record
about them yeah i still don't think
that's an act that's been done i don't
think it's mostly unprecedented most
people on there tend to not go on there
and say hey guys no no i didn't actually
do that i did this instead
and i think so that's when that's like
the correct me if i'm wrong that is one
of the biggest catalysts right so what
kickstarted
the fascination that people have with
chris yeah and
um it basically fed the trolls because
they received so much information so
much personal information about chris
and this included one particular drawing
of chris
and
their friend at the time their female
friend
being uh satisfied
in a certain way
yes
yeah that's that got a lot of attention
too obviously right
yeah
i think i think later on uh chris also
mentioned uh or christine at that time
uh mentioned that uh yeah they thought
that it was okay to draw sexual pictures
of someone because they weren't actually
taking like doing the sexual thing to
them or something yeah also chris chris
in a video or no chris in a in a
personal email said that they made that
drawing
in order to
to um release their certain urges
instead of acting it out in person wait
personal email to who personally emailed
to the female friend oh yeah
justification i do remember this was in
a previous episode right yeah so they
were like oh i'm not gonna do anything
to you that's why i'm drawing stuff so
that i don't do anything to you
which must be an extremely concerning
email to receive this person just like
the human yikes machine like well that's
the problem is that every time
when you watch this documentary when
you're reading about uh chris which is
just worrying in itself
every time you want to
give chris a chance and root for chris
yeah something happens where you're like
[ __ ] yeah every time she's that close to
getting the w she does something
especially early on i feel like in the
start of the in the history you you very
much are rooting for
chris to just stop just please just stop
just getting off the internet
uh raising money for charity or
something you know you know
and i think there was one turning point
for me where i was like oh for [ __ ]
sake uh when i was watching this and i
think it was uh i don't think they do
this anymore but chris at the time uh
would you say racist things and was
quite homophobic very often yep and it
was just to the point where i was like
you know and i wonder how much of that
was due to the environment that they
were raised in
yeah i feel like
it raised very difficult questions where
it was like
is this your fault or is this your
environment's fault that you're a race
and you haven't been educated better
like is this how you actually are where
you're like orchestrated by people well
it's hard to say you know because i feel
that
uh they're a very impressionable person
i felt like you can definitely tell
whatever that was told to them as a
child uh was stuck with them quite a lot
right so i i it's a very conflicting
thing especially because chris does have
autism quite severe autism you do
you almost want to
justify certain things but then every
single time you want to justify well i'm
sure it's you know something else
happens yeah well you're like for [ __ ]
sake i am trying my best to want you to
do good on your side i'm trying my best
here
yeah you know just i'm just like you
know like that domino meme yeah it
that it is literally the massive domino
like chris chan draws sonic shoe and it
ends with sleeping with his mother
like i'm just like what happened in
between how did we get to this point